a new beginning for nick cannon and bree
tiacy she is literally ready at any
second to have nick's eighth child and
in part two of our exclusive at-home
visit brie answers the big question how
in the world does this busy dad plan on
keeping up with all those children
how do you split time or how will nick
you know how often will he be able to
come see you son i mean that all
obviously dictates what's going on in
his work schedule um we all can go
through the assistant to make sure it's
on the calendar if there's something
important um
but anything you say you need from him
this man always shows up so tell me
about the delivery will nick be here yes
nick will absolutely be here he has no
choice
but i'm actually having it at the house
i'm gonna have our son here and just i'm
doing it on medicated as well so brave
woman we'll see we'll see if i regret
this
at first nick wasn't fully on board with
the home birth especially since losing
his five-month-old son zen last december
from brain cancer he is a little
concerned especially you know he has a
sensitive after a loss he's a little bit
more sensitive now
so i wanted to respect that but i also
was like i'm the one birthing him so he
was like i'll support you and if
anything we go to the hospital do you
have a name i do i had come up with one
name and he jazzed it up a little bit
it's not like
too
out there
so it'll be a little bit different i
feel like one day there could be a show
called the cannons or something like
that
could there maybe would you do reality
tv yeah i would i don't know if i would
go necessarily housewife vibe but i
ended up getting a really amazing
opportunity which i can't share just yet
for now bree and nick's beautiful
nursery is all ready to welcome their
baby boy alex cash helped me do this
entire design and when i saw it i fell
in love with it
look at these amazing knitted jordans so
cute we're gonna dress them up and
i can't wait people seem to be very
opinionated about your relationship and
they're like how is she doing it why is
she doing this he's got too many
children yeah for me i really just kind
of it doesn't actually genuinely affect
me they're used to their conventional
relationships that's what we're taught
that's what's instilled in us
but stuff like whatever you want to call
this has been going on forever